en poursuit sur le même sujet avec notre
collaborateur Charles Côté bonjour
Charles
bonjour Isabelle alors on le sait ça va
être long comme enquête et si on
concluait que c'est pas accidentel
qu'est-ce qui pourrait y avoir comme
accusation déposée contre un éventuel
suspense
on peut penser déjà dans les incendie
criminel
de par une négligence
généralisée face aux normes
minimale d'entretien de l'immeuble pour
s'assurer que les occupants sont en
sécurité face à un éventuel incendie on
peut parler également
d'accusation de négligence criminelle
causant la mort si on est capable de
démontrer au terme de l'enquête et d'un
procès que le propriétaire
a fait preuve d'une négligence téméraire
et de mesurer par rapport à la norme de
responsabilité normale ou de deux alors
mais il y a également je vous dirais
à identifier qui est responsable des
locations entre autres sur le site
Airbnb parce que le locataire qui aurait
mis son appartement en location
pourrait avoir une certaine
responsabilité quant au lieu loué à
savoir est-ce qu'il y avait un détecteur
de fumée dans l'appartement lui-même qui
était fonctionnel est-ce que
l'espace loué était également
conforme et permettait une évacuation
sécuritaire alors tout ça sera déterminé
au terme de l'enquête oui je trouve
qu'on couvre extrêmement large dans la
réponse que vous nous faites Charles
quand on parle incendie criminel en tout
cas quand on pense incendie criminel on
voit tout de suite le cocktail Molotov
qui est lancé dans une fenêtre mais
l'incendie criminel ça peut être autre
chose qu'un cocktail Molotov ou de
l'accélérant jeté dans un endroit avec
une allumette
l'installation n'est pas au norme au
code du bâtiment qui fait en sorte que
peut-être l'électricité était
défaillante le panneau électrique était
désuet à une certaine problématique
vous savez peut-être que justement le
fait que l'immeuble était en location
temporaire comme ça sur Airbnb peut-être
que les policiers vont trouver des
commentaires qui faisaient état de
problématiques dans les lieux
généralisés des photographies qui vont
démontrer que le bâtiment était pas au
nord qui ne permettait pas des sorties
adéquates en cas de sinistre alors tout
ça s'il y a une on voit
négligence téméraire dans les normes de
sécurité applicables pour un immeuble
résidentiel ben là on peut parler d'une
négligence criminelle qui pourrait être
à éviter aux propriétaires justement ça
c'est la responsabilité du propriétaire
cette série de petits manquements pas de
sortie de secours ou pas de fenêtres
dans certains des appartements ça c'est
la responsabilité du propriétaire de
l'immeuble
oui effectivement c'est la petite donc
ils auraient un enfer à en faire la
preuve que c'est pas un locataire qui a
modifié son appartement pour créer une
petite pièce à louer à partir d'un
garde-robe existait vous savez
une sorte de scénario possible qui
devront être éliminés par les policiers
bon s'il y avait pas d'accusation
criminelle imaginons ça scénario là et
qui est seulement des accros au code du
bâtiment par exemple pas d'avertisseur
de fumée est-ce que ce serait indiqué
quand même des mettre des constats
d'infraction mais ça a l'air tellement
dérisoire ou ridicule est-ce qu'on
pourrait faire ça quand même
ouais mais il faut regarder aussi la
nature des manquements si ce sont des
mangements bénins effectivement
ça va être un incendie malheureux qui
aurait fait de nombreuses victimes mais
sans responsabilité criminelle mais si
on constate un écart par rapport à la
norme et de la responsabilité minimale
d'un propriétaire d'un immeuble à
logement et alors à partir de ce
moment-là les autorités vont être tentés
d'explorer beaucoup plus loin la
responsabilité criminelle du
propriétaire est envisager des
accusations de négligence alors s'il y a
plusieurs
l'addition de toutes les de toutes les
infractions ou de tous les manquements
pourraient équivaloir à de la négligence
effectivement en terminant rapidement
oui tout à fait on va parler un petit
peu de cette présence de Airbnb illégaux
d'enlever Montréal et on peut on se
demande nous est-ce que ultimement la
plateforme elle-même pour être accusée
et si oui de quoi
non c'est justement leur cheval de
bataille des décisions l'effet que ils
ne sont que l'entremetteur de duffre de
service mais ultimement c'est le
propriétaire ou le la personne qui met
en location temporaire les lieux qui est
ultimement responsable alors il se
dégage de leur responsabilité de cette
façon là
et c'est leur cheval de bataille en tout
temps au même titre que facebook se dit
on est seulement une plateforme où on
relaie des informations alors c'est bien
facile de s'en laver les mains mais on
suivra cette enquête merci infiniment
sur le côté
ça m'a fait plaisir au revoir pour voir
nos émissions en entier rendez-vous sur
la chaîne ici RDI